the sudden closure of college campuses
across the country over the coronavirus
sent millions of students home early I
know I've got one here who's behind the
camera this morning a 19 year old from
bu while many are learning online
college seniors are telling us about
their sense of loss our national
correspondent
Jericka Duncan spoke to some who said it
was an abrupt departure
Jericka good morning good morning to you
Anthony
you know these students barely had any
time to pack up their things and leave a
lot of folks said that they had to leave
their belongings on campus and the
students we've talked to big picture
overall said that they're thankful that
they're healthy that they're safe but
they can't help but feel they were
cheated out of their senior year I
really wanted to walk across that stage
not only for myself like for her Daniela
Medina is a senior at University of
Central Florida Orlando her mother
worked up to three jobs at a time to get
her through college she's the reason I'm
here I wouldn't be sitting in this room
at UCF if it weren't for my mom if they
have a different ceremony later on it
won't really like fill that void it's so
hard it's heartbreaking heartbreaking
not just for Daniela but for millions
across the country whose lives as
students came to an abrupt halt
I didn't know it was happened like as
quickly as it did
it was sort of chaotic and crazy like
Stanford University senior Gregory Clark
he left campus in such a rush to get
home to his family in North Carolina
that his belongings are still in his
dorm I got a call on Sunday sort of
saying like it's time to go and that
Monday morning I was on a plane back
home so I didn't really have time to say
goodbye to anyone he says he's worried
about how the pandemic will affect his
future I was talking with a potential
employer a few days ago and they told me
that they actually couldn't go forward
in the application process because a
hiring freeze had been instituted
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
labor market going forward it's just
really scary thinking about that
and what's that next step going to be a
concern shared by Adelphi University
senior Morgan Louie brand right now I'm
in a position where I have no idea
what's gonna happen you know I have
anxieties about even being able to
graduate her classes have been moved
online which is difficult for a nursing
student who relies on hands-on
experience I can practice whatever I
want but you know if I'm not in a
hospital doing patients patient care at
the end of the day I'm like am I really
even learning to the best of my ability
do you feel prepared to enter the
workforce as a nurse without those
critical hours to be completely honest
no I don't but she's staying positive
and embracing something her professor
told her that 2020 is the year of the
nurse I'm missing out on senior formal
senior dinners my nursing pinning
ceremony that inducks me into the
nursing Association you know I'm missing
out on those memories with my best
friends but I'm trying to just look at
it in a perspective of this is all gonna
make me a better nurse and that's just
what I'm holding on to right now Morgan
said that she'd like to volunteer
wherever she's needed at any hospitals
she actually filled out a survey to do
that so perhaps that's how she will get
that hands-on experience meanwhile NYU's
medical schools actually graduating its
medical students early so that they can
help fight this pandemic all right
shriek oh wow that really brings it home
I mean there's the acute disappointment
right now of not being with a walk not
seeing your friends and then there's the
long-term worry of well I thought I was
gonna have a job and now this company is
not hiring people nobody's hiring but I
can understand you know this is so much
bigger than any of us could have
anticipated but I can understand why
it's so crushing Anthony I know you
understand
I lose my cameraman at nine o'clock to a
class on line alright we'll hurry it up
Anthony we'll be back